seguramente has escuchado hablar del
ácido en tu vida diaria pero lo que
queremos hacer en este vídeo es obtener
una definición más formal de un ácido y
en particular enfocarnos en la
definición de ácido que se utiliza más
frecuentemente aunque vamos a ver en
algunos otros vídeos que hay otras
definiciones de ha sido bastante
utilizadas pero la definición en la que
nos vamos a enfocar en este vídeo es la
definición de ácido de browns usted lo
lee ok vamos a ver la definición de
ácido base de brawn usted lo lee esta es
una foto de brawn usted esta es una foto
de lori y a estas dos personas se les
ocurrió una definición de ácido base muy
buena en la década de 1920 así es que
vamos a ver la definición de browns de
dolor y
definición de browns de lori y de
acuerdo a brawn usted olor y un ácido es
un donador de protones donador de
protones protones y en realidad en lugar
de escribir protones también podemos
escribir simplemente un hidrógeno con
carga positiva ahora porque un protón y
un átomo de hidrógeno con una carga
positiva son lo mismo pues resulta que
en el isótopo más común del hidrógeno en
el núcleo encontraríamos simplemente un
protón y ningún neutrón y bueno si es un
isótopo neutral además del protón
también podemos encontrar un electrón
que está flotando alrededor del protón
porque encontraríamos a este electrón
saltando en su orbital ahora sí
guionizados a este hidrógeno o sea si le
quitamos este electrón lo único con lo
que nos vamos a quedar es con este
protón de aquí y es por eso que tener
y un átomo de hidrógeno con carga
positiva es exactamente lo mismo
así es que aquí ya tenemos nuestra
definición de bronx de dolor y de ácido
pero ahora pensemos en que es una base
y que sería una base pues una base sería
algo que acepta protones acepta protones
o bueno también podemos decir que acepta
átomos de hidrógeno con carga positiva
bueno ya ahora vamos a hacer esto un
poco más tangible con algunos ejemplos
uno de los ácidos más fuertes que
conocemos es el ácido clorhídrico que es
un hidrógeno que tiene un enlace
covalente con un átomo de cloro ahora
sería muy bueno dibujar los otros
electrones del cloro por aquí sabemos
que en este enlace covalente el cloro
está aportando un electrón pero además
tiene otros tres pares de electrones
libres ok ahora si nosotros tomáramos el
ácido clorhídrico y lo pusiéramos en una
solución acuosa y bueno generalmente
para denotar que estamos poniendo algo
en una solución acuosa lo que hacemos es
poner entre paréntesis
aquí hace de la cosa así es que esto de
aquí significa que estamos poniendo al
ácido clorhídrico en una solución acuosa
o sea en una solución de agua
simplemente lo podemos expresar
simplemente así o para hacerlo todavía
más explícito podemos poner por aquí las
moléculas de agua así es que vamos a
poner por aquí nuestra molécula de agua
que es un oxígeno con dos pares de
electrones libres
dos enlaces covalentes con otros dos
hidrógenos ok entonces este paréntesis
con ace significa que tenemos el ácido
clorhídrico en una solución de agua
líquida por aquí tenemos a nuestras
moléculas de agua y muchas veces para
denotar que está en su estado líquido lo
que hacemos es poner entre paréntesis
una l aunque bueno yo ya dije que este
es un ácido muy fuerte entonces sabemos
que este va a querer donar su protón
aunque iba a querer donar este hidrógeno
pero además quedarse con el electrón de
este hidrógeno y donar únicamente el
protón así es que lo más probable es que
estos dos electrones de este enlace
covalente van a quedarse con este átomo
de cloro y luego pues este hidrógeno
como el cloro se quedó con su electrón
puede ser que pase por ahí una molécula
de agua y se quede con este ión de
hidrógeno
además recuerda que cuando estamos en
una solución no es que estas moléculas
sepan qué es lo que tienen que hacer
simplemente tenemos un montón de
moléculas chocando unas contra otras y
dependiendo de qué tan fácilmente
suceden algunas cosas que tanto estos
electrones se quieren quedar con el
cloro y ese tipo de cosas
las reacciones se dan así es que nos
podemos imaginar como este par de
electrones libres del oxígeno puede ser
que llegue y forme un enlace covalente
con este protón de aquí así es que qué
es lo que va a pasar y únicamente estoy
dibujando una flecha hacia la derecha
por aquí porque esta es una reacción que
favorece muchísimo ir hacia la derecha
porque porque el ácido clorhídrico es un
ácido muy fuerte entonces todo el tiempo
va a estar sucediendo la reacción hacia
la derecha y entonces qué es lo que nos
va a quedar por aquí pues aquí tenemos
el cloro
que tenía sus tres pares de electrones
libres pero además se está quedando con
los dos electrones de este enlace
covalente por lo cual tiene otros dos
electrones libres aunque tiene un
electrón de más así es que ahora tiene
una carga negativa y ahora se llama
unión cloruro pero a ver qué pasa con la
molécula de agua pues tenemos por aquí
el oxígeno que tiene dos hidrógenos
pero ahora no solo tiene a estos dos
hidrógenos ok porque este par de
electrones libres hizo un enlace con
este protón de aquí que ahora voy a
dibujar a este hidrógeno con otro color
para que lo distinga es mejor entonces
el oxígeno ahora tiene un enlace
covalente con este hidrógeno este vídeo
que no lo ponemos por aquí y estos dos
electrones ahora están formando este
enlace de aquí también tenemos estos
otros dos enlaces covalentes con estos
otros dos hidrógenos y todavía tenemos
este otro par de electrones libres
ok tenemos aquí el otro par de
electrones libres y ahora pensemos en
qué es lo que le acaba de pasar a la
molécula de agua pues la molécula de
agua acaba de ganar este protón del
hidrógeno ok
este hidrógeno no venía con todo y un
electrón era simplemente un protón así
es que si esta molécula de agua tenía
una carga neutra
ahora tiene una carga positiva así es
que qué es lo que pasó en esta reacción
pusimos el ácido clorhídrico en una
solución acuosa o sea en una solución de
agua líquida y esta cosa le donó un
protón a la molécula de agua así es que
cuál es el ácido y cuál es la base pues
como podemos observar este de aquí es un
ácido ácido y bueno de hecho esto se
llama ácido clorhídrico y aquí el agua
está actuando como una base base y bueno
de hecho como vamos a ver el agua puede
actuar como ambas puede actuar como
ácido y como base pero en esta reacción
está actuando como una base ahora tú
podrías llegar y decir me oye yo sé que
esta reacción es una reacción que
favorece muchísimo moverse hacia la
derecha lo que hay es una reacción que
generalmente va de izquierda a derecha
y por aquí yo veo a este año en cloruro
con una carga negativa y me puedo
imaginar muy bien como en algunas
circunstancias este año el cloruro
podría aceptar un protón porque tiene
esta carga negativa y diciéndome eso
estarías en lo correcto es cierto que
esta reacción fluye hacia la derecha
pero una vez que un ácido donó un protón
a lo que queda del ácido después de
donar el protón se le llama la base
conjugada ok de hecho lo vamos a
escribir con el mismo color este año en
cloruro es la base conjugada del ácido
clorhídrico
base con jugada de el ácido clorhídrico
y por otro lado el libro neo es el ácido
conjugado del agua
ok seguramente en alguna circunstancia
el idóneo podría donar un protón sin
donar ni un solo electrón a alguna otra
cosa así es que el idóneo es el ácido
conjugado de h2o
y cómo vamos a ver en algún momento el
agua puede funcionar como ácido o como
base pero bueno por lo menos este es un
buen ejemplo de un ácido y una base de
brousset lori y también quiero agregar
una cosa por aquí tenemos el ácido
clorhídrico y dijimos que lo ponemos en
una solución acuosa y aquí tenemos esta
reacción así sin embargo en algunos
libros lo escriben diferente porque lo
voy a escribir por aquí con un poco
menos de detalle pero en algunos libros
ponen el ácido clorhídrico
que está en una solución acuosa o sea
una solución de agua y simplemente
escriben como sucede la reacción y nos
quedan unos guiones de hidrógeno que
siguen estando en una solución acuosa y
también nos quedan algunos en iones
cloruro que también están en nuestra
solución acuosa ahora esto de aquí no
está mal solo es importante que nos
demos cuenta de qué es lo que está
sucediendo aquí aunque porque si tenemos
una solución de agua estos iones del
líder o neo no se quedan sentados
flotando por ahí generalmente va a
llegar una molécula de agua y va a ser
un enlace con estos iones formando
moléculas de hidrógeno así es que aunque
esto no esté mal estamos escribiendo
mucho mejor lo que está pasando cuando
hablamos de la formación de idron yo en
lugar de hablar simplemente de los
protones porque hay por qué estos
protones van a formar un enlace
covalente con alguna molécula de agua
formando hidronew y es por eso que
describía esta reacción de esta forma